the taliban are celebrating the
withdrawal of american troops and
proudly showing off the equipment the
u.s military left behind the victors
still face what could be an even bigger
challenge in the war charlie dagetta
reports on what the future holds for
afghanistan under taliban rule he's in
doha qatar charlie good morning
good morning the taliban says they are
now close to announcing a new government
just one or two days away now but for a
country on the verge of collapse it
can't come quickly enough
taking over the country was the easy
part now comes the job of running it
like the airport where taliban members
holding american weapons bad mouth
outgoing u.s forces
as you can see these infidels have
destroyed the entire airport he says we
had a team ready to fix this mess now
the americans have gone we're ready to
clean it up it's now a graveyard of u.s
military hardware and bereft of the
technical know-how to even get a
reliable air traffic control system in
place the taliban are now turning to
qatar and turkey to get it back up and
running
even with flights stopped some afghans
tried to get in taliban guards turn them
away
then there's the financial system there
has been a run on the banks with
panicked people trying to withdraw cash
in the chaos some have waited in line
for days i should build a future i
should study uh so definitely if the
situations are like that uh that you
should stay for one week just to take 10
000 afghan 100 from a bank so it's not
possible to live here
with many employees now too terrified to
return to work even basic necessities
like electricity and water are under
threat the un has already warned of an
absolute catastrophe of economic ruin
and even famine
yesterday crowds attended a mock funeral
held by the taliban coffins draped in
flags of america and coalition allies
but as celebrations subside the country
may soon be facing more funerals of its
own
in fact between the conflict and a
widespread drought the u.n now warns the
country is marching towards starvation
and some regions could run out of food
within a month
tony charlie dagetta for us in doha
again charlie thank you very much